la administración de alimentos y drogas
de estados unidos encontró que la vacuna
de johnson y johnson que es de solo una
dosis es segura efectiva y previene las
hospitalizaciones y muertes por causa
del convite además de la vacuna de facer
y de moderna esta sería la tercera en
aprobarse en eeuu donde se registran
esta semana más de medio millón de
muertes por la pandemia
la vacuna de johnson y johnson podría
ser aprobada a más tardar este fin de
semana después de que el viernes se
reúnan los científicos para dar el visto
bueno final
según la fd a la vacuna tiene un 85 por
ciento de efectividad en los casos
severos y un 66% en los casos moderados
un índice menor de efectividad que las
dos vacunas anteriores sin embargo ésta
también tiene niveles de eficacia altos
contra la variante del virus de brasil y
de sudáfrica los especialistas de la
salud ven con buenos ojos la llegada de
esta vacuna porque además de que sólo se
necesita una dosis ésta puede ser
almacenada por meses y no necesita del
cuidado
picado en bajas temperaturas como las
vacunas de modernas y facer esto
permitiría entonces que el proceso de
vacunación en eeuu se acelere y alcance
el objetivo desde que para el 4 de julio
la mayoría de los estadounidenses estén
vacunados
hay que mencionar que ya hay más de 44
millones y medio de personas vacunadas
en este país